you know I was able to sort of step back
over the last few years and step out of
the limelight for a second and kind of
look at everything from an objective as
objectively as I could and I just needed
to live a little bit and kind of take
some time off and come up with some new
material to write about tonight and I
love doing what I do for a living it's
very rare that you can make a living
doing this he has stolen the hearts of
millions with his music charming good
looks and we can't forget that voice and
he's here today to do it again Jesse
McCartney is no stranger to dropping
hits and he is in the house
Jessie welcome Jesse McCartney the house
music yeah music let's just start from
the beginning a beautiful soul riot 2004
you dropped this amazing album that song
was everywhere I have to say Jessie that
I went to several weddings that year in
the following year and a lot of the vows
as they had lyrics from beautiful soul
yeah talking about the song well I mean
it was it was sort of my debut it was my
debut record it was the song sort of put
me on the map and kind of introduced me
to um you know every home in America I
was I don't know 15 16 when it came out
and I remember when it when I first
heard it on the radio I was and I tell
this story a lot but I was coming out of
high school finishing my SAT exam yeah
and not feeling very good about the math
portion of the exam and like really
bummed out thinking like immediately man
I'm have to take this over and then I
come I jumped in my car and I turned on
the radio and I heard it for the first
time and I remember thinking like I'm
not gonna be a mathematician Who am I
kidding like my songs on the radio right
now and it was beautiful soul and that
was sort of like the beginning of my
career and and it's you know here we are
you know years later still making music
yeah I have to ask though because you
hearing your song on the radio I mean
that just doesn't happen for everyone
kid just give me pinpoint like what was
that feeling like for you cuz it blows
my mind to hear you say that back just
hearing your song on the radio I mean
it's you know it's something you dream
about and it's such a surreal experience
it's an out-of-body experience when
you're a kid all you want to do is pick
up a mic and start singing right you
don't care really who's listening and
then when you find out that everyone is
listening it's certainly a validating
moment right now you're like wow maybe
true maybe this is where I what I'm
supposed to be doing
and so just it totally turns your world
around turns your life around and and
that's at that point that's when I
picked up and I moved to Los Angeles I
grew up in a little small town in New
York moved to LA and the rest was was
history right you I mentioned that you
took a step back I mean you've had such
success as an actor musician
pop star Jessie pop star you took a step
back why why why did you decide to well
I mean I mean jumping you know ten years
later after you know putting on numerous
records traveling the world touring
being on you know a bunch of television
shows
I had like just sort of a point in which
I realized like I I hadn't gotten a
chance to really stop smell the roses
enjoy all the places that I had just
traveled to I just needed a little break
I literally have been at this since I
was nine years old and so it was about
the time was 25 26 years old I kind of
just needed to step back relax I got
myself a house you know I fell in love I
started traveling I got to actually see
the cities I was going to I took up
different hobbies I did a bunch of
acting and writing projects that I
wanted to work on I went to Nashville
and did some country songwriting just
because I wanted to and then you know it
was about two two and a half years ago I
decided I need to I need to get back on
the horse so to speak and my whole team
was like so are you done making music
because we think you should be back out
there and eventually I I got back and
you know into the studio but it you know
I I just felt like I needed a little bit
of me time and because when you're when
you're out there doing this for a living
you're giving so much of yourself all
the time that it's nice to have a little
bit you know have a moment for yourself
so but I'm glad I'm back because these
next few songs I just put out are
already making a huge splash with all of
my fans and I'm now getting new fans out
on the road so
it's it's it's good to be back in the
music game yeah for years and I mean you
you just you just mentioned that you
know you gave so much of yourself and
you and you kind of have to water your
own spiritual garden during that time
what was one of the most profound things
you learned about yourself during that
time away would you say or like any
hobbies you got into your because you
did a lot of regular people think yeah
yeah yeah yeah what is the one of the
things I've learned most about myself
that I that I really truly love food and
to cook you know that that that I love
to travel and and for me like I just
wanted to take that I love nature I
think in this crazy world that I live in
were constantly consumed with media and
content we're on our phones all the time
I was just talking to a friend of mine
about this we're we're we're constantly
on and wired to do it on that I've
realized now that when I reach for like
something to decompress it's usually
like nature or the sea or hummingbird
documentaries how many I don't know I
just I'm making that up but maybe but
you know like just wit stuff that just
kind of brings you back to a primal self
yeah yeah so so that's something I
discovered in my time off I just kind of
got to be one with you know nature and
and food and cooking and it was nice
listen you've mentioned food and cooking
word on the street is he can you can
grill a mean steak dress I can grill I
can smoke I do a lot of like smoking I'm
like BBQ smoking so this year we're
gonna smoke I'm actually gonna smoke a
short rib my girlfriend's gonna roast a
turkey for Thanksgiving but I'm gonna do
like a short rib on the on my smoker and
yeah we're big into food like you're so
passionate about smoke in this short
that it's amazing you you're back
musically what has been where has
inspired you to return what was it was
there something that something you heard
what was a niche to really I think just
my fans you know my fans made it pretty
clear that they wanted new music and
they were getting a little I think they
were just a little uh getting a little
bit impatient the fact that it been
almost four years since I've put
anything new out I had merely toured in
a while and and you know music is my
first love I always knew that I was
going to come back to at some point I
just didn't realize would be that long
of a gap chore
you know I did some I was in a writing
camp in Nashville that sort of sparked
some creativity and and kind of I think
was the catalyst for me wanting to get
back into the studio and you know and
just the outcry and the pouring outcry
of my fans who have been loyal for so
many so many years you know they one of
the great things about social media
despite its the fact that we can get
consumed in it sometimes is that they
can reach out to you directly and say
hey like what's going on where are you
at or hey we like this song we're not
really feeling this song or and and
having that connection now with my fans
is really sort of impacted my career in
in a positive way that's that's so
wonderful to hear Jessie I this is to go
deep with you were you scared where you
know you guys because in four years away
there was a little apprehension thinking
like of course yeah I mean from Gifford
to get back in you mean yeah I think so
I mean you know anyone who walks away
for that period of time I think there's
always like this fear is like are they
gonna have me back or will they still
care about my music and you know I sort
of didn't know what was gonna happen but
like I said there there was sort of like
this core group of fans that would write
to me and say hey we really miss your
stuff or it got me through this awful
moment in my life at this pivotal moment
in my life and you know what's going on
like we really want to hear songs again
and then and but then there's like the
masses right you know yeah well maybe
they won't care and and release it
better with you which I put out early as
far this year I think really came at a
time it was you know that the song was
released and it was much about its
timing I think then then it was just
it's writing it was a really crazy time
in in the country there was a lot of
division we had just come off of an
election and I wrote this song called
better with you just like this feel-good
song it was very reminiscent of like the
earlier days the beautiful soul days
right and it just like came at the right
time and I think it really hit struck a
chord with my fans and and it was all of
a sudden I was just like it was but I
was back at it so I think it just takes
it takes one great song and it takes
your truth you know full attention and
and and your you know and your ability
to connect with your fans I mean I guess
that's the biggest thing yeah better
with you is this this acoustic guitar
lead love affirmation and you have the
new the new song wasted which is a
complete 180
it's a different thing which is amazing
has this tropical vibe
we've been jamming it all day in the
office why why they need to experiment
with new sounds I mean look I like to
write kitschy fun up you know pop catchy
songs like that's kind of what I feel
like I'm good at and wasted is like it's
a song
it's cheeky but it has heart it's about
a guy who wants more than just that 2:00
a.m. booty call right and and and it's
and it's just a catchy fun pop song is
it's really there's not a lot to it
other than you know you listen to it and
it's hard not to sing along that's you
know it's purposely written to be catchy
and I think after better with you which
has a little bit more of a serious tone
or a little bit more of a heartfelt tone
it was nice to do something a little bit
more lighthearted and a little bit more
you know just a just a fun record so
we're gonna shoot a video in the next
couple weeks which is exciting and and
then we're gonna tour the beginning of
next year to sort of you know push the
single as well so but so far people I
think are super into it they're
definitely into it I really want to
touch on the songwriting because you
know a lot of people think that stars
don't write their own songs I mean you
had you you wrote one of the most
amazing songs for Leona Lewis with Ryan
Tedder bleeding love which was number
one in several countries when you're
writing a song emotionally what does
that take you what's that process for
you
well I mean it depends I mean for the
mode it's different every time and you
don't really know what you're gonna get
I think going in you know that 95% of
your work is never gonna be heard so you
always have that in the back your mind
so you need at the beginning you're just
kind of like you know you're hoping for
for greatness but usually it doesn't
happen like that's the first thing you
remember I think if you always if you
always put the pressure on yourself to
write something unbelievable every time
I think writing will get boring and just
kind of you'll you won't connect with it
as much I think you have to keep sort of
your expectations down a little bit
that being said that 5% of 10% of the
time you do write something great it
makes it worth all the while and for me
it can happen in the back of a uber it
can happen on an airplane I'll think of
something you know it's like hmm what if
we made like you know your veins like
that are rushing with blood or you know
or your heart is pounding out of your
chest and like
word association and then write it all
down and then get in the studio and try
to put something together and in this
case it was something like bleeding love
where it's just kind of you're comparing
the the heart and the anatomy with being
madly in love with somebody and
sometimes it sounds awful most of the
time it does but once in a while you
strike you strike Matt you know you have
a magical moment yeah right it's it's a
fun you talk about because I write every
time I hear bleeding love I think of
like oh my god you know like cut me it's
just but yeah that that's so on the
money you said earlier that you dabbled
in country a little bit have you always
been a country fan it was no actually I
had not always been a country fan but
now I'm a huge country fan the last five
years I've been really listening to a
lot of country and like my girlfriend's
a huge Jason Aldean fan and Thomas Rhett
and oh you should be Casa de Laura one
of the hosts were huge sure but so I but
I really didn't I didn't know much about
country I didn't grow up listening I
grew up listening to soul and R&B and
pop music and so I got an invitation to
go down to Nashville and write some
country music and I was a little scared
just because I did some territory new
world for me but they were trying to
infuse pop writers into the country
world and I think that's happening a lot
in the crossovers were there and so they
were bringing in pop writers and I sat
down got into the studio with both pop
writers and country writers and we did
this sort of Nash pop writing camp and
basically a writing camp is when writers
get together and they write a bunch of
songs in hopes that some country artists
will will publish one or some record one
and so yeah I have a catalogue of
country music that I've recorded that I
don't know will ever see the light of
day okay first of all everyone watching
they we want yeah that well maybe at
some point if I run out of stuff to put
out it I could I might drop that and
then not telling get it I know but it
was it was such a it was just such a
cool experience to write something sort
of out of your comfort zone and country
writing is really just it's like the
ultimate storytelling you know so I
enjoy that genre music very much so new
music new tour yep resolution tour can
up
no I so when I was when I was going down
the Jesse McCartney rabbit hole as I did
all day today first CD you bought was
crazy
from TLC yeah great now first of all
smash on that album um you're going on
this tour who would it be some special
guest you want on this tour I haven't
thought about that actually I guess I
should I just actually I just a direct
message mike posner today cuz we met
like a week ago
and I just I'm waiting to hear back cuz
he was trying to we were actually
recording something very similar we were
it was in a live studio for billboard
and we were doing something and
basically he knocked on the door and we
were live and I couldn't like talk to
him so he had to leave but I've always
loved his writing I think he's a super
talented songwriter he is um so I don't
know we'll see we'll see if he deal he
slides back into my DMS but uh so yeah
and then I don't know I mean I'd love to
do a duet at some point with you know
with a female artist I have I don't know
if I've ever really done that I toured
the Jordin Sparks many years ago and
that was a lot of fun but yeah I'm open
to collabs I just haven't we haven't
locked anything down just yet yeah I'm
more concerned with my own material and
making sure that all of my songs sound
good live before I worry about anyone
else on my well we'll cross that bet
opening guest feature that's where
you'll become that's it
[Music]